this year I've gotten really into pro
football maybe it's getting to host the
NFL honors I don't know or the fact that
literally every human that surrounds me
is obsessed with the game but I now am
very into it and our next guest is one
of the voices of the game you can see
her hosting throughout this season on
NFL Network say hello to MJ
[Music]
[Applause]
aosta
so excited you're here likewise like I'm
I just got into it okay like really into
like I'm in fantasy football too same I
have two leagues it's too much oh I'm
going to have more than one yeah I I I I
that's an undertaking that's a
commitment it is an undertaking but it's
so you get so much joy and you actually
start to learn about the other teams
100% as used to I just only cared about
the Cowboys which is fair I get it it's
America team I will say thank you for
saying it not me being part of fantasy
football is like my sneaky trick as a
sportscaster to make sure that I'm up on
every single game across the entire
league because you're invested you're in
it you get upset when you lose which on
one of my leagues I'm abysmal and the
other one I'm crushing it so you know
multiple links does help with the
self-esteem a little yeah so wait you
you started in broadcast while a pro
cheerleader which I didn't actually know
that yeah that's incredible did you do
both at the same time like most things
in my life I'm doing all the things all
the time all all at once um yeah look at
that it's so tremendous I was already a
sports caster um when I made the Miami
Dolphins cheerleading team um fun fact
though I tried out five times to be a
Miami Dolphins cheerleader before I
actually made the team so tenacity also
a central
theme thank you um I tried out in my not
to age of myself in my early 20s it was
very long tedious process U made it so
close every time so I decided let's
focus let's focus on the career path
let's focus on other dance opportunities
and even once I started my career I had
this this little tug at me if I don't
try this at least one more time while I
still have flexibility early on in my
career I'm going to regret it and sure
enough that was the year I made it made
it huge Advantage being on the sidelines
watching the game develop in front of me
in real time being part of a franchise
invaluable experience that still helps
me to this day in my career that's so
cool I never really think about that but
I think that's so cool that yeah you
were on the field like getting that and
hearing everybody
now you can hear people because every
time now they're miked up hey here we go
you he
it good cence here we go it's like every
time he does a play
Dak every time it's like a lot it's deep
in the diaphragm hey it's like it's
every time you're going to hear it now
if you're watching a game I love you D I
love you so I love that you also talk
about this you don't play down your
femininity at all no cuz I feel like
some I feel like a lot of women feel
like they do have to do that 100% I
think not only the industry and there
are so many tropes um and I think a big
challenge for me at the beginning was
because I was an NFL cheerleader which
by the way was one of the toughest
things I ever had to do was so much
discipline so much dedication it's one
of the things that I'm proudest of and
many folks at the beginning of my career
told me yeah you probably shouldn't lead
with that why when was the last time you
were on the sideline of a game the
entire time remind me again I didn't
think so um and beyond that I think oh I
love you I think you can thank you kie I
think being hyper feminine or not
whether you're a tomboy wherever you are
and however you are is how you should
arrive every day to work and that's very
hard in sports casting it's very hard in
just the entertainment industry and I
refused to sort of push myself into this
little box that they were constantly
trying to shove me and it would be
disingenuous one and it would not serve
the folks who watch us who want to see
themselves reflected and want to see
themselves represented on the screen or
on social media um so for me it was very
important to remind folks that I don't
have to strip away my femininity to show
you that I'm credible and qualified for
my job
[Applause]
absolutely I and you're the perfect
Mentor you love mentoring and you're
kind of the perfect mentor to do that
because that is like what people need to
hear especially young women in this
industry that's important to you right
mentorship no question it's been one of
the biggest parts of now this this stage
of my career because I think when I
started out they were even fewer women
than there are now it has evolved a bit
but we still have such a long way ago
but there were even fewer who were um
really there for you step by step cuz
when they started out they didn't have
every anyone so for me it was very
important to break that cycle um and I
remember at the Super Bowl back in Miami
which was such a beautiful moment in my
career to be there and to show everyone
around and to do these feature
interviews had just saying it's
fantastic merch the colors were
phenomenal um we had a dinner myself and
one of my colleagues um at the NFL
league office put together a dinner
called a seat at the table and the whole
purpose of the dinner was to create a
pipeline between the women who were were
already in the industry and the ones who
were up next to have a direct
face-to-face connection and say okay not
only are we breaking the door off the
hinges no holding it open we're tearing
that thing apart but we're going to be
there with you every step of the way so
you know that you're not alone and no
one understands the challenges better
than we do we're here to navigate and
help you through and hopefully make it a
little little easier than it was for us
yeah and I think it's cool too cuz it
gets women more involved too exactly
that we have a young aspiring sports
analyst here and she also has no idea
that MJ is here and that MJ has a giant
surprise for her as well so MJ's going
to hide for a little bit and we're going
to bring her out just the right moment
so I'm going to say bye right now but
see you in a second at 12 years old our
next guest is the ultimate football
fanatic so I had to have her on she
seriously doesn't miss a single NFL game
she notes every stat and reates key
plays endlessly just for fun which is so
cool but for her football is not just a
passion she actually wants to make it a
career so everybody Welcome
Ali hello hi so I'm recently in love
with football so I'm I'm you're going to
know way more than me but I'm so excited
about it um so wait so if what's your
favorite team um my favorite team is the
Kansas City Chiefs oh that's a good one
okay they got they have great initials
yes I like them um uh no mine's the
Cowboys I love the cow don't talk don't
you look at me like that
girl I love them so much no I'm going
say Mahomes is he one of your favorites
yes definitely my favorites yes I would
say he's pretty talented yeah so wait do
you want to make football like a career
definitely absolutely yeah and you want
to be like broadcasting like what do you
want to do um I feel like it can really
depend on each day I kind of feel like I
want to do something different um I love
watching the new heights podcast the
Kelsey Brothers I think they're great
they're hilarious yeah I love them yeah
um so something like that like watching
and analyzing the game and giving facts
and background knowledge to people who
aren't the biggest fans of football or
who don't know football incredibly well
just making it access I love people like
you yeah then you inform yes that's why
I love listening to the commentators the
um analysts like all that because I'm
just I'm new to it so it's a really cool
thing because then you get to bring new
people into the sport definitely yeah um
so I know that you're early in your
career path but we have someone here
who's as passionate about sports
broadcasting as you are so she wanted to
meet you cuz she's very impressed so
she's an ammy winning sports caster and
to us she is a whole lot of woman
y'all okay so say hello to MJ
[Music]
aosta
she think you're amazing I think you're
amazing
[Applause]
oh my good surprise good surprise yeah
yeah she's doing something you might
want to be doing later what impresses
you most about this one first of all I'm
already a huge fan another curlfriend we
need more that here um I think just the
fact that you love the game so much
already you're already a fan of it but
also an analyst at it too so even if
you're not on television right the fact
that you're in it is already a huge step
you're way more ahead than I was at your
age that's for certain um but the fact
that you want to bring this to folks who
may not understand the intricacies of
the game and all the X's and O's that's
what's missing that's the missing link
so I love that you're representing not
just the Next Generation but really such
a big gap that is still need to be
served um throughout the NFL so
congratulations you're crushing thank
you so much course absolutely you want
to tell her about maybe an opportunity
so I want to make sure that you can
continue I she can her
face she can't I your face you got gifts
for days I I want to make sure sure that
you can continue down this path and that
any opportunity you want to follow so I
want to offer you my mentorship we can
have several different Zoom sessions I
can help you out with anything you want
and next time that I'm in New York I
want you to Shadow me and so you can see
what the day in the life is
like of course of course oh my God I'm
so I'm so looking forward to this read
just to be able to Shadow her I think
you're going to love that what do you
think I'm so excited like I love it
great oh my God I can't wait to hear
what it's like afterwards I'm kind of
jealous I want to Shadow her too CU I'm
newly obsessed
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home